hi everyone uh welcome to the 224n
hugging face Transformers tutorial
um so this tutorial is just going to be
about using the hugging face Library
it's really useful in a super effective
way of being able to use kind of some
off the shelf NLP models specifically
models that are kind of Transformer
based and being able to use those for
either your final project your custom
final project or something like that
just using it in the future so these are
it's a really helpful package to to
learn and it interfaces really well with
pi torch in particular too
okay so first things first is in case
there's anything else that you are
missing from this kind of like tutorial
the hugging face documentation is really
good they also have lots of kind of
tutorials and walkthroughs as well as
other kind of like notebooks that you
can play around with as well
so if you're ever wondering about
something else that's a really good
place to look
okay so in the collab the first thing
we're going to do uh that I already did
but can maybe run again is just
installing the Transformers python
package and then the data sets python
package so this corresponds to that
hugging face Transformers and data sets
um and so those are really helpful the
Transformers is where we'll get a lot of
these kind of pre-trained models from
and the data sets will give us some
helpful data sets that we can
potentially use for various tasks so in
this case sentiment analysis
okay and so we'll use a bit of like a
helper function for helping us
understand what encoding is uh what
encodings are actually happening as well
so we'll run this just to kind of kick
things off an important a few more a few
more things
okay so
um so first what we'll do is this is
generally kind of like the step by step
for how to use something off of Hocking
face so first what we'll do is we'll
find some model
um from like the hugging face Hub here
and note that there's like a ton of
different models that you're able to use
there's bird there's gpt2 there's T5
small which is another language model
from Google
um so there are a bunch of these uh
different models that are pre-trained
and all of these weights are up here in
hugging face that are freely available
for for you guys to download so if
there's a particular model you're
interested in you can probably find a
version of it here you can also see kind
of different types of models on the side
as well that for a specific task so if
we wanted to do something like uh zero
shot classification there are a couple
models that are specifically good at
doing that particular task okay so based
off of what tasks you're looking for
there's probably a hugging face model
for it that's available online for you
to download
okay so that's what we'll do first is
we'll go ahead and find a model on the
hug and face Hub and then
um you know whatever you want to do in
this case we'll do sentiment analysis
and then there are two things that we
need next the first is a tokenizer for
actually you know splitting your input
text into tokens that your model can use
and the actual model itself
um and so the tokenizer again kind of
converts this to some vocabulary IDs
these discrete IDs that your model can
actually take in and the model will
produce some prediction based off of
that
okay so
um so first what we can do is again
import this Auto tokenizer and this Auto
model from uh for sequence
classification so what this will do
initially is download some of the you
know key things that we need so that we
can actually initialize these so what do
each of these do so first the tokenizer
this Auto tokenizer is from some
pre-trained tokenizer that has already
been used so in general there's a
corresponding tokenizer for every model
that you want to try and use in this
case it's like cbert so send like
something around sentiment and Roberta
and then the second is you can import
this model for sequence classification
as well from something pre-trained on
the model Hub again so again this
corresponds to sentiment Roberta large
English and if we want we can even find
this over here
um we can find it as
um
I think English yeah large English so
again this is something we can easily
find you just copy this string up here
and then you can import that
okay we've downloaded all of the kind of
all the things that we need some kind of
like binary files as well and then now
we can go ahead and actually you know
use some of these inputs right so this
gives you some set of an input right
this input string I'm excited to learn
about hogging face Transformers we'll
get some tokenized inputs
here from the actual tokenized things
here after we pass it through the
tokenizer and then lastly we'll get some
notion of the model output that we get
right so this is kind of some legits
here over whatever classification that
we have so in this case good or bad and
then some corresponding prediction okay
and we'll walk through what this kind of
looks like in just a second as well a
little more depth but this is broadly
kind of like how we can actually use
these together we'll tokenize some input
and then we'll pass these inputs to the
model
so we'll talk about tokenizers first so
um so tokenizers are used for basically
just pre-processing the inputs that you
get for any model and it takes some raw
string to like
um essentially a mapping uh to some
number or ID that the model can take in
and actually kind of understand
so tokenizers are either kind of like
are specific to the model that you want
to use or you can use the auto tokenizer
that will kind of conveniently import
whatever corresponding tokenizer you
need for that model type
um so that's that's kind of like the
helpfulness of the auto tokenizer it'll
kind of make that selection for you
um and make sure that you get the
correct tokenizer for whatever model
you're using so the question is uh does
it make sure that everything is mapped
to the correct index that the model is
trained on the answer is yes so that's
why the auto tokenizer is helpful
so there are two types of tokenizers uh
there's the a Python tokenizer and
there's also like a tokenizer fast that
the tokenizer fast is written in Rust in
general if you do the auto tokenizer
it'll just default to the fast one
there's not really a huge difference
here it's just about kind of like the
inference time for getting the model
outputs
yeah uh so the question is the tokenizer
uh creates dictionaries of the model
inputs
um so I to think it's more like I think
the way to think about a tokenizer is
like that
um like that dictionary almost right so
you want to kind of translate almost or
have this mapping from the tokens that
you can get from like this string and
then map that into kind of some inputs
that the model will actually use so
we'll see an example of that in just a
second
so for example we can kind of call the
tokenizer in any way that we would for
like a typical Pi torch model but we're
just going to call it on like a string
so here we have our input string is
hugging face Transformers is great we
pass that into the tokenizer almost like
it's like a function right and then
we'll get out some tokenization so this
gives us a set of input IDs so uh to
answer the earlier question these are
basically the numbers that each of these
tokens represent
so that the model can actually use them
and then a corresponding attention mask
for the particular Transformer
okay
so there are a couple ways of accessing
the actual tokenized input IDs you can
treat it like a dictionary so hence kind
of thinking about it almost as that
dictionary form it's also just like a
property of the output that you get so
there are two ways of accessing this in
like a pretty pythonic way
okay
so what we can see as well is that we
can look at the particular the actual
kind of tokenization process almost and
so this can maybe give some insight into
what happens at each step right so our
initial input string is going to be
hugging face Transformers is great
okay the next step is that we actually
want to tokenize these individual kind
of uh individual words that are passed
in so here this is the kind of output of
this tokenization step
right we get kind of these individual
split tokens we'll convert them to IDs
here
and then we'll add any special tokens
that our model might need for actually
performing inference on this
okay
so there's a couple steps that happen
kind of like underneath when you use an
actual we use a tokenizer that happens
at it a few things at a time
one thing to note is that for fast
tokenizers as well there's another
option that you're able to get to
so you have essentially right you have
this input string you have the number of
tokens that you get you might have some
notion of like the special token mask as
well right so using Char to word is
going to give you like the word piece of
a particular character in the input
so here this is just giving you
additional options that you can use for
the fast tokenizer as well for
understanding how the tokens are being
used
um in the from the input string
okay uh so there are different ways of
using the outputs of these tokenizers
too so one is that you know you can pass
this in and if you indicate that you
want it to return a tensor you can also
return a pi torch tensor so that's great
um in case
you need a pie torch tensor which you
probably generally want
you can also add multiple tokens into
the tokenizer and then pad them as
however you need so for here for example
we can use the pad token as being this
kind of like pad bracket almost and
giving the token ID is going to
correspond to zero right so it's just
going to add padding to whatever input
that you give so if you need you need
your outputs to be the same length for a
particular type of model right this will
add those padding tokens and then
correspondingly gives you like the zeros
in the attention mask where you actually
need it
okay and so the way to do that here is
uh you basically set padding padding to
be true you can also set truncation to
be true as well and so if you ever have
kind of like
um more uh
any other kind of like features of the
tokenizer that you're interested in
again you can check the hugging face
documentation which is pretty thorough
for what each of these things do
yeah so the the question is kind of
looking at
um looking at the the hash hash at least
and whether that means that we should
have like a space before or not so
um so here in this case
um yeah so the in this case uh we
probably don't want like the space
before right just because
um we uh have like the hugging like I
don't know hugging is all one word
um in this case
um generally like generally the uh for
like the tokenizers generally the output
that they give is still pretty
consistent though
um in terms of how the tokenization
process works so there might be kind of
these like you know instances where it
might be contrary to what you might
expect for kind of how something is
tokenized
um in general the tokenization generally
works fine
um so
in most cases kind of like the direct
output that you get from the hugging
face tokenizer is sufficient
foreign
okay awesome so one last thing past the
adding kind of additional padding is
that you can also kind of uh decode like
an entire batch at one one given time so
if we
um look again we have like uh our
tokenizer we'll initially have this
method called like a batch decode so if
we have like the model inputs that we
get up here this is the output of
passing these sentences or these strings
into the tokenizer we can go ahead and
just pass like these input IDs that
correspond to that into the batch decode
and it'll give us kind of this good this
decoding that corresponds to all the
padding we added in each of the
particular kind of like uh words and
strings
um and if you want to you know ignore
all the the presence of these padding
tokens or anything like that
um you can also pass that into skipping
the special tokens
gotcha so this gives like a this is a
pretty high level overview of the how
you would want to use tokenizers I guess
in your
um in using hugging face
so now we can talk about maybe how to
use the hugging face models themselves
so again this is this is pretty similar
to what we're seeing for something like
initially using a tokenizer you just
choose the specific model type
um for your model and then I and you can
use that or the specific kind of Auto
model class where again this Auto model
kind of takes almost the
um like the initialization process it
takes care of it for you in a pretty
easy way without really any too much
overhead
um so additionally so
um for the pre-trained Transformers that
we have they generally have the same
underlying architecture but you'll have
different kind of heads associated with
each Transformer so attention head so
you might have to train if you're doing
some sequence classification or just
some other task so hugging face will do
this for you and so for this I I will
walk through an example of how to do
this for sentiment analysis
um so if there's a specific context like
sequence classification we want to use
we can use like this the very specific
kind of like Class A hugging face
provides so distilbert for sequence
classification
alternatively if we were doing it using
distilbert in like a mass language model
setting we use distilbert for Mast LM
and then lastly if we're just doing it
purely for the representations that we
get out of distilled bird we just use
like the Baseline model so the key thing
here or key takeaway is that there are
some task specific classes that we can
use from hugging face to initialize
so Auto model again is similar to kind
of like the auto tokenizer so for this
it's just going to kind of load by
default that specific model and so in
this case it's going to be just like
kind of like the basic basic weights
that you need for them
okay
so
um so here we'll have basically three
different types of models that we can
look at one is like an encoder type
model which is Bert
a decoder type model like gpt2 that's
like uh performing these like uh you
know generating some text potentially
and encoder decoder models so Bart or T5
in this case so again if you go back to
kind of the the hugging face Hub there's
a whole sort of different
um different types of models that that
you could potentially use and if we look
in the documentation as well
so here we can understand some notion of
like the different types of classes that
we might want to use right so there's
some notion of like the auto tokenizer
different Auto models for different
types of tasks
um so here if again if you have any kind
of like specific use cases that you're
looking for then you can check the
documentation here again if you use like
an auto model from pre like pre-trained
you'll just create a model that's an
instance of that or model
in this case root model for the burst
Burt based case
okay Let's uh we can go ahead and start
one last thing to note is that like
again the particular choice of your
model matches up with kind of the type
of architecture that you have to use
right so there are different these
different types of models can perform
specific tasks so you're not going to be
able to kind of load or use Bert for
instance or distill Bert as like a
sequence to sequence model for instance
which requires the encoder and decoder
because distill distilber I only
consists of an encoder so there's a bit
of like a limitation on how you can
exactly use these but it's basically
based on like the model architecture
itself
okay awesome so let's go ahead and get
started here
um so similarly here we can import so
Auto model for sequence classification
so again this is we're going to perform
some classification tasks and we'll
import this Auto model here so that we
don't have to reference again just like
something like distilbert for sequence
classification we'll be able to load it
automatically and it'll be all set
alternatively we can do distillburt for
sequence classification here and that
specifically will will require
distilbert speed the input there okay so
these are two different ways of
basically getting the same model here
one using the auto model one using just
explicitly distiller
cool and here because it's
classification we need to specify the
number of labels or the number of
classes that we're actually going to
classify for each of the input sentences
okay so here we'll get some like a
warning here right if you are following
along and you print this out because
some of the sequence classification
classification parameters aren't trained
yet and so we'll go ahead and take care
of that
so here similarly we'll kind of like
walk through how to
um how to actually you know train some
of these models so the first is how do
you actually pass any of the inputs that
you get from a tokenizer into the model
okay well if we get some model inputs
from the tokenizer up here
and we pass this into the model by
specifying that the input IDs are the
input IDs from the model inputs
and likewise we want to emphasize or we
can you know show here and specifically
pass in that the attention mask is going
to correspond to the attention mask that
we gave from these like these outputs of
the tokenizer
okay
so this is option one where you can
specifically identify which property
goes to what
the second option is using kind of a
pythonic
hack almost which is where you can
directly pass in the model inputs and so
this will basically unpack almost the
keys of like the model inputs here so
the model input keys so the input IDs
correspond to this the attention mask
corresponds to the attention mask
argument
so when we use this star star kind of
syntax this will go ahead and unpack our
dictionary and basically map the
arguments to something of the same keys
so this is an alternative way of passing
it into the model
both are going to be the same
okay
so now what we can do is we can actually
print out what the model outputs look
like so again these are the inputs the
token IDs and the attention mask
and then second we'll get the actual
model outputs so here notice that the
outputs are given by kind of these
legits here there's two of them we
passed in one example and there's kind
of two potential classes that we're
trying to classify
okay and then lastly we have of course
the corresponding distribution over the
labels here here right since this is
going to be binary classification
yes it's like a little bit weird that
you're going to have like the two
classes for the binary classification
task and you could basically just choose
to classify one class or not
um but we do this just basically because
of how hugging face models are are set
up
um and so uh Additionally you know these
are the models that we load in from
hugging face are basically just Pi torch
modules so like these are the actual
models and we can use them in the same
way that we've been using models before
so that means things like lost dot
backward or something like that actually
will do this back propagation step
corresponding to the loss of like your
inputs that you pass in so so it's
really easy to train train these guys as
long as you have like a label you know
label for your data you can calculate
your loss using you know the pi torch
cross entropy function
you get some loss back and then you can
go ahead and back propagate it
you can actually even get kind of the
parameters as well
um in the model that you're would
probably get updated from this
this is just some big tensor of the
actual embedding weights that you have
okay we also have like a pretty easy way
for hugging face itself to be able to to
calculate the loss that we get so again
if we tokenize some input string we get
our model inputs we have two labels
positive and negative
um and then give some kind of
corresponding label that we assign to
the the model inputs and we pass this in
we can see here that the actual model
outputs that's that are given by a
hugging face includes this loss here
right so it'll include the loss
corresponding to that input anyways so
it's a really easy way of actually
calculating the loss just natively in
hugging face without having to call any
additional things from a pie torch
Library
and lastly we can actually even use
um if we have kind of like these two
labels here
again for positive or negative what we
can do is just take the model outputs
look at the legits and see which one is
like the biggest again
we'll pass that and take it to the ARG
Max so that'll give the index that's
largest and then that's the output label
that the model is actually predicting
so again it gives a really easy way of
being able to do this sort of like
classification getting the loss getting
what the actual labels are just from
within hugging face
okay awesome so
um well last thing as well is that we
can also kind of look inside the model
um in a pretty pretty cool way and also
seeing what the attention weights the
model actually puts uh the attention
weights the model actually has so this
is helpful if you're trying to
understand like what's going on inside
of some NLP model and so for here we can
do again I where we're importing our
model from some pre-trained kind of
pre-trained model model weights in the
um the hugging face Hub we want to
Output attention set output attentions
to true and output hidden states to true
so these are going to be the key
arguments that we can use we're actually
kind of investigating what's going on
inside the model at each point in time
again we'll set the model to be in eval
mode
and lastly we'll go ahead and tokenize
our input string again
we don't really care about any of the
gradients here
um again so we don't actually want to
back propagate anything here and finally
pass in the model inputs
so now what we're able to do is when we
print out the model hidden States so now
this is a new kind of property in the
output dictionary that we get we can
look at what these actually look like
here
um and sorry this is a massive output
so you can actually look at the hidden
State size per layer right and so this
kind of gives a notion of what we're
going to be looking like looking at like
what the shape of this is at each given
layer in our model
as well as the attention head size per
layer so this gives you like it the kind
of shape of what you're looking at
and then if we actually look at the
model output itself we'll get all of
these different like hidden States
basically right so
um so we have like tons and tons of
these different hidden States we'll have
the last hidden State here
so the model output is pretty robust for
kind of showing you what the hidden
state looks like as well as what
attention weights actually look like
here
so in case you're trying to analyze a
particular model this is a really
helpful way of doing that
so what model.eval does is it sorry
question is what is the dot eval do
um what it does is it basically sets
your and this is true for any PI torch
module or model is it sets it into
quote-unquote eval mode so again for
this like we're not really trying to
calculate any of the gradients or
anything like that that might correspond
to
um like correspond to some data that we
pass in or try and update our model in
any way we just care about evaluating it
on that particular data point
um so for that then it's helpful to set
the model into like eval mode
essentially to help make sure that that
kind of like disables some of like that
stuff that you'd use during training
time so it just makes it a little more
efficient
yeah the question was uh it's already
pre-changed so can you go ahead and
evaluate it yeah you you can so yeah
this is just the raw pre-trained model
with no no fine tuning
so the question is like how do you
interpret
um these shapes basically uh for the
attention head size and then the hidden
State size so um so yeah the the key
thing here uh is you'll probably want to
look at kind of the shape given on the
side it'll correspond to like the layer
that you're actually kind of like uh
looking at so here
um like when we call we looked at the
shape here we're specifically looking at
like the first first one in this list
right so this will give us the first
hidden layer all right the second gives
us a notion of kind of like the the
batch that we're looking at and then the
last is like so this is like some tensor
right 768 dimensional I don't know
representation the corresponds there
um and then for the attention head size
it corresponds to like the actual query
word and the keyword for these last two
here
but yes so um but for this you know we
would expect this kind of initial index
here right the one to be bigger if we
printed out all of the you know all of
the layers but we're just looking at the
first one here
so we can also do this
um
for
um you know actually being able to get
some notion of how these different how
this actually like looks
um and plot out these axes as well so
again if we take this same kind of model
input which again is like this hugging
face Transformers is great we're
actually trying to see like what do
these representations look like on like
a per layer basis so what we can do here
is basically we're looking at for each
layer that we have in our model right
and again this is purely from the model
output attentions or the actual outputs
of the model
so what we can do is for each layer and
then for each head we can analyze
essentially like what these
representations look like and in
particular what the attention weights
are across each of like the tokens that
we have so this is like a good way of
again understanding like what your model
is actually attending to within each
layer so on the side if we look here
maybe zoom in a bit we can see that this
is going to be like corresponds to the
different layers and the top will
correspond to these are across the the
different attention heads okay this will
just give you some notion of like what
the weights are
so again just to um to clarify so again
if we maybe look at the labels sorry
it's like a little cut off and like
zoomed out but so this y-axis here like
these different rows corresponds to the
different layers within the model oops
um on the x-axis here right we have like
the
um like the different attention heads
that are present in the model as well
and so for each head we are able to for
each at each layer to basically get a
sense of like what how the attention
distribution is actually being
distributed what's being attended to
corresponding to each of like the tokens
that you actually get here
so if we if we look up again
um here as well right we're just trying
to look at like basically the model of
tensions that we get
for each kind of corresponding layer
the question is what's the the color key
um yellow is like higher higher
magnitude and higher value and then
darker is like closer to zero so
probably very Navy is like zero
so what we can do is now maybe walk
through like what a fine-tuning task
looks like here
um and so first like uh in a project you
know you're probably going to want to
fine-tune a model
um that's fine it's a and we'll go ahead
and walk through an example of what that
looks like here
okay so what we can do as well
is all right
what we can do as well is use some of
the
um the data sets that we can get from
hugging face as well so it doesn't just
have models it has really nice data sets
and be able to kind of like load that in
as well so here what we're going to be
looking at is uh looking at like the
IMDb data set
um and so here again is for sentiment
analysis I will just look at only the
first 50 tokens or so
um and generally
so this is this is like a you know a
helper function that we'll use for
truncating the output that we get
and then lastly for actually kind of
making this data set we can use the data
set dict class from a hugging face again
that will basically give us this smaller
data set that we can get for the uh for
the train data set as well as specifying
what we want for validation as well
so here what we're going to do for our
like mini data set for the purpose of
this demonstration is we'll use I make
train and vowel both from the IMDb train
data set uh we'll Shuffle it a bit and
then we're just going to select here 128
examples and then 32 for validation so
it'll Shuffle it around it'll take the
first 128 and I'll take the LA the next
32.
um
and then we'll kind of truncate those
particular inputs that we get again just
to kind of make sure we're efficient
and we can actually run this on a CPU
okay
so next we can do is just see kind of
what does this look like it'll just
again this is kind of just like a
dictionary it's a wrapper class almost
of giving you know your train data set
and then your validation data set
and in particular you can even look at
like what the first 10 of these looks
like
so first like the output so we specify
train we want to look at the first 10
entries in our train data set
and the output of this is going to be a
dictionary as well which is pretty cool
so we have some the first 10 test text
examples that give the actual movie
reviews here
um so this is the given in a list
and then the second uh key that you get
are the labels corresponding to each of
these so whether it's positive or
negative so here one is going to be a
positive review 0 is negative
so it makes it really easy to use this
for some something like sentiment
sentiment analysis
okay
so what we can do is go ahead and
prepare the data set and put it into
batches of 16. okay so what does this
look like what we can do is we can call
the map function that this like uh this
small like data set dictionary has so we
call map
and pass in a Lambda function of what we
want to actually do so here the Lambda
function is for each example that we
have
we want to tokenize the text basically
so this is basically saying how do we
want to you know pre-process this
um and so here we're extracting the
tokens input IDs that will pass as a
model we adding padding and truncation
as well we're going to do this in a
batch and then the batch size will be
16.
hopefully this makes sense
okay so
um next we're basically just going to
um
uh do like a little more modification on
what the data set actually looks like so
we're going to remove the column that
corresponds to text and then we're going
to rename the column label to labels so
again if we see this this was called
label we're just going to call it labels
and we're going to remove the text
column because we don't really need it
anymore we just have gone ahead and
pre-processed our data into the input
IDs that we need
okay and lastly we're going to set it
the format to torch so we can go ahead
and just pass this in pass this into our
model or Pi torch model
the question is what is labels so um so
label here corresponds to like again the
first in the context of sentiment
analysis it's like just yeah positive or
negative and so here we're just renaming
the column
okay so now we'll just go ahead and see
what this looks like again we're going
to look at the train set and only these
first two things
and so
um so here now we have the two labels
that correspond to each of the reviews
and the input IDs that we get
corresponding for each of the reviews as
well
lastly we also get the attention mask so
it's basically just taking the what you
get out from the tokenizer and it's just
adding this back into the data set so
it's really easy to pass in
the question is we truncated which makes
things easy but how do you want to apply
like padding evenly so here if we do
pass in so first is like you could
either manually set some high truncation
limit like we did the second is that you
can just go ahead and set padding to be
true and then basically like the padding
is basically uh
added I based off of kind of like the
longest
um like longest sequence that you have
yeah so the question is I guess doing it
for all of them all the text lists
evenly
um so again it just like depends on like
the size of like the data set you're
you're like you're loading in right so
if you're looking at particular batches
at a time you can just pad within that
particular like batch versus like yeah
you don't need to like load all the data
set into memory pad the entire data set
like or like in the same way so it's
fine to do it within just batches
yeah the question was how does uh how
were the input IDs like added and uh
yeah the answer is yes it's basically
done automatically
um so we had to manually remove the text
column here and that kind of like this
first line here buy it
um like if you recall like the outputs
of token like at the tokenizer it's
basically just the input IDs and the and
the attention mask so it just is smart
enough to basically aggregate those
together
um
okay the last thing we're going to do is
basically just put these so we have this
like data set now
um that looks great we're just gonna
import like a pytorch data loader
typical normal data loader and then go
ahead and load each of these data sets
that we just had I mean specifying the
batch size to be 16.
okay so that's fine and great and so now
for training the model it's basically
like exactly the same as what we would
do in typical pytorch so again it's like
you still want to compute the loss you
can back propagate the loss and
everything
um
yeah so it's it's really up to your own
design how you do uh how you do the
training
um so here there's only like a few kind
of asterisks I guess one is that you can
import specific kind of optim Optimizer
types from the Transformers uh package
so you can do atom with weight Decay you
can get a linear schedule for like the
learning rate which will kind of
decrease the learning during the
learning rate over time for each
training step so again it's basically up
to your choice but if you look at the
structure of like this code right we
load the model for classification we set
a number of epochs and then however many
training steps we actually want to do
we initialize our Optimizer and get some
learning rate schedule
right and then from there it's basically
the same thing as what we would do for a
typical kind of like Pi torch model
right we set the model to train mode we
go ahead and pass in all these batches
from like the the data loader and then
back propagate step the optimizer and
everything like that
so it's I pretty pretty similar from
what we're kind of like used to seeing
essentially
awesome so that'll go do its thing at
some point
um okay and so I so that's one potential
option is if you really like pie torch
you can just go ahead and do that and
it's really nice and easy
um the second thing is I that hugging
face actually has some sort of like a
trainer class that you're able to use
that can handle most of most of these
things so again if we do the kind of
like the same thing here this will
actually run one star model is done
training
um
like we can create the our you know our
data set in the same way as before
now what we can what we need to use is
like this import of like a training
arguments class so this is going to be
basically a dictionary of all the things
that we want to use when we're going to
actually train our model and then this
kind of like additional trainer class
which will handle the training kind of
like magically for us and kind of wrap
around in that way
okay anyways so if you can okay I think
we're missing a directory but
um
I think yeah pretty straightforward for
how you want to train yeah
um so for for here at least again there
are kind of the two key arguments the
first is training arguments so this will
specify have a number of specifications
that you can actually pass through to it
it's where you want to log things for
each kind of like device in this case
like we're just using one GPU but
potentially if you're using multiple
gpus what the batch size is during
training or the batch sizes during
evaluation time
how long you want to train it for
how you want to evaluate it so this is
kind of like evaluating on an Epoch
level
what the learning rate is and so on so
on so again if you want to check the
documentation uh you can see that here
there's a bunch of different arguments
that you can give there's like warm-up
steps warm-up ratio like weight Decay
there's like so many things
um so again it's basically like a
dictionary feel free to kind of like
look at these different arguments you
can pass in but there's a couple key
ones here and this is basically this
basically mimics the same arguments that
we used before in our like explicit Pi
torch method here for hugging face
okay similarly
um what we do is we can just pass this
into the trainer and that will take care
of basically everything for us so that
whole training Loop that we did before
is kind of condensed into this one class
function
um for actually just doing the training
so we pass the model the arguments the
train data set eval data set what
tokenizer we want to use and then some
function for computing metrics
so for here we pass in this function uh
eval and it takes eval predictions as
input basically what this does is these
predictions are given from the trainer
passed into this function and we just
can split it into the actual legits and
the labels that are predicted or sorry
the ground truth labels that we have and
then from here we can just calculate any
sort of additional metrics we want like
accuracy
F1 square recolors and whatever you want
okay so this is like an alternative way
of formulating that training Loop
okay uh the last thing here as well is
that we can have some sort of callback
as well if you want to do things during
the training process so after every
Epoch or something like that you want to
evaluate your model on the validation
set or something like that or just go
ahead and like dump some sort of output
that's what you can use a callback for
and so here this is just a login
callback it's just gonna
log kind of like that information about
the the process itself again not super
important but in case that you're
looking to try and do any sort of
callback during training it's an easy
way to add it in the second is if you
want to do early stopping as well so
early stopping will basically
um stop your model early as it sounds if
it's not learning anything and a bunch
of epochs are going by and so you can
set that so that you don't waste kind of
like compute time or you can see the
results more easily the question is is
there a good choice for the patient's
value
um I think it just depends on the model
architecture not really I guess this is
It's a
yeah pretty up to your discretion
okay awesome and so the last thing that
we do
um is just do call trainer.train so if
you recall this is just the
instantiation of this trainer class we
all trainer.train and it'll just kind of
go so now it's training
which is great it gives us a nice kind
of estimate of
how long things are taking what's going
on what arguments do we actually pass in
um
so that's just going to run and then
likewise hopefully it'll train
relatively quickly okay it'll take two
minutes we can also evaluate the model
um pretty easily as well so we just
called trainer.predict
on whatever data set that we're
interested in so here it's the tokenized
data set corresponding about the
validation data set
okay hopefully we can pop that out soon
um and lastly so if we saved anything to
our model checkpoints so hopefully this
is
um
saving stuff right now
yeah so this is going to be is
continuing to save stuff to the folder
that we specified
and so here in case we ever want to kind
of like load our model again from the
weights that we've actually saved we
just pass in the name of the checkpoint
like the relative path here to our
checkpoint so notice how we have some
checkpoint 8 here
right we just pass in the path to that
folder we load it back in be tokenized
and it's the same thing as as we did
before
there are a few kind of additional
appendices for how to do like different
tasks as well there's appendix on
generation how to define a custom data
set as well
how it's a kind of like pipeline
um different kind of like tasks together
um so uh so this is kind of like uh
using some a pre-trained model that you
can just use through kind of like the
pipeline interface really easily
um there's like in different types of
tasks like Mass language modeling but um
feel free to look at through those at
your own time and uh yeah thanks a bunch